dad's of your boy key job to make a
sandwich my daddy's in the thing I'm
here maybe in the kitchen the fridge at
Olga what are you doing back I'm
rummaging around the fridge to see if I
find something edible it didn't matter
if the me had a little hue to it it's
really better you know my god daddy as
usual eat that you ever been to war
Louie he would put stuff on a sandwich
that was available so let's say it's
after Thanksgiving Wow
look this for the most part is available
you know picking up the bread for your
sandwich crucial here's the popular bond
now it's like the cheerleader bond the
pretzel bond I want a pretzel bun the
pretzel bun weighs a pound a pound and a
half that's all and then this is a
second favor but I mean if you could
smell this right now you would crawl in
it Oh hold on five as out come back for
me you need some utensils and I always
when I'm at the restaurant I just I'm
gonna give it back I'm not gonna keep it
I like to put a coat of something on the
bun we've got some delicious mustard
here oh you can never open these things
who makes these things nobody who's old
makes these things you have to bite them
this is a brown mustard I don't want to
overwhelm the sandwich with mustard
I just want Turkey to know that mustard
is a rogue so then I like to just put a
fuse you know downpours of mayonnaise on
it now turkey celexa i love turkey who
doesn't love turkey and if you can get
it right off the bird do it carry a
cartridge with you oh it's a delicious
turkey mmm I'll put that right there
beautiful win this kitchen I might lay
down on you I might not even finish this
family then I'm gonna take the dressing
I'm gonna be a little gross here because
dressing a roll on
now here's something nice a little gravy
I don't like to overwhelm the sandwich
with gravy no one likes a runny sandwich
I get a secret thing I do and this isn't
healthy
they're not just regular ruffle chips
they're sour cream and onion oh then you
get this bad boy huh
cranberry look at that oh my god it
looks like it should be crime scene
paper on this if you made the sandwich
correctly look at that cut that baby in
half and there you have it look at that
bad boy
but Louie's leftovers one bite of this
can take you back to 1965 at the NW
drive-in with my dad and my mom and my
little brother mmm oh I loved it it was
so much fun oh here's some butter
look here's butter thank you